welcome to hannity tonight we are at the
beginning of what is poised to be
another awful week for your president
joe biden when you think it couldn't get
any worse think again economists are now
warning that tomorrow's inflation report
is likely to be very ugly prices
continue to rise no end in sight we'll
get the official numbers tomorrow but
experts now fear it could be as high as
8.4 percent uh that would be a number we
have not seen since 1981.
so the question tonight is how is gen
saki and the biden administration going
to explain this how to control inflation
let's see they're going to blame putin
trump opec the pandemic or pretend that
inflation is a good thing all the above
probably but of course we know the
administration will take zero
responsibility this is their
bad economic policies bad energy
policies causing all of this but
according to them every bad thing that
happens is totally completely out of
their control even though they were the
ones that suppressed america's oil and
gas capabilities they artificially
reduced the world's supply and lo and
behold you're paying record prices and
paying more for every item you buy in
every store you go to and by the way
they also printed an obscene amount of
money during joe biden's first year in
office now with china's major trading
hub watching what's happening in
shanghai not a lot of people talking
about it they're facing a dystopian
lockdown amid new omicron surge albert
cron 2.0 as we're calling it or ba2 is
the medical community refers to it our
own supply chain it is now going to be
pushed beyond anything we have ever
witnessed before and right now it's
pretty bad because this country imports
massive amounts of phones and computers
and chips and other electronics from
china so you can expect those costs to
shoot through the roof if you can even
get them and as per usual biden is not
prepared for any of this there is no
plan b for this administration to bring
down prices curb inflation or ease the
pain at the pump they're just telling
you to go out and buy an electric car or
until we get uh cleaner
renewable energy well you're just going
to have to pay the freight of high gas
prices they keep saying it and laughing
about it and blaming everyone but
themselves as a result biden's approval
numbers they continue to plummet a new
cbs
news poll has their lowest number for
joe biden in fact joe is underwater on
almost every single major issue look at
this 61 percent of americans disapprove
of his handling on crime 62 percent
disapprove uh his policies on
immigration that would be the border
disaster
63 percent disapprove his handling of
the economy 69 percent yep they know joe
caused inflation and meanwhile 55
percent also disapprove of joe's
handling of ukraine and for good reason
now the images from putin's invasion
they are horrific it is evil in our time
look at these pictures thousands of
innocent civilians now have been
slaughtered others tortured millions
displaced entire towns and cities and
villages have been leveled cities
reduced to rubble we are witnessing a
humanitarian crisis on a scale not seen
since world war ii and yet where is the
urgency from joe biden over the weekend
during an interview on 60 minutes so
it's probably the best segment i will
say this 60 minutes is probably done in
15 years and that is the interview with
scott pelley with president zielinski
and zielinski held nothing back calling
out nato the u.n security council what
good is the security council if you
don't provide security and joe biden
also the u.n for dragging their feet in
the face of nothing but pure evil watch
this
in speaking to nato you called them weak
in speaking to the u.n security council
you said if you can't help you shouldn't
exist
not very diplomatic of you
i wonder why you feel the need to speak
so bluntly
aggressive diplomatic when you're
working at diplomacy there are no
results
all of this is very bureaucratic
that's why the way i am talking to them
is absolutely justifiable i remember all
of us remember books about the second
world war and about the devil in uniform
adolf hitler
are those countries who did not
participate in the war responsible
the countries who let german forces
march throughout europe
does the world carry responsibility for
the genocide
yes
yes it does what are you asking of
president biden
to tell you the truth long ago i asked
president biden for very specific items
he has the list
as i've said many times biden cannot put
u.s boots on the ground and by the way
president zielinski is not asking for
that the only disagreement i might have
with him is on the no-fly zone issue but
we can get ukraine and by the way nato
countries ought to be stepping up the
urgency so should joe biden so should
all of western europe he's asking for
the weapons so that the ukrainians can
defend freedom in their own land they're
not asking for our boots on the ground
they need the weapons they need the ammo
they need it yesterday so they can drive
russia out of their country and they're
willing to do the fighting themselves
and we need to do it as soon as possible
when you look at biden nato western
europe they have not shown the necessary
urgency for this moment in history over
the weekend british prime minister boris
johnson he did make a surprise trip to
keeve to support zielinski got to give
him a lot of credit don't expect a
similar trip from your president joe
biden according to joe
they won't let him go i'm not allowed to
take questions or anything they get mad
at me when i go back in the other room
you're the president joe you want to go
to the kiev go to keeve today our own
jackie heinrich asks just who they are
this is interesting take a look
have the president ask to go to ukraine
i'm not going to get into private
conversations uh what i will tell you is
we're not uh currently planning a trip
um by the president of the united states
to ukraine what is most important to the
ukrainian leadership is that we are
expediting weapons and getting them the
assistance and security systems they
need and that is what our focus is on
who decides if the president goes to
ukraine or not
in what way he had said when he was in
poland that he expressed interest in
going to ukraine but they wouldn't let
me so i'm wondering who i'm not going to
get into private considerations
internally on that front
they won't let me really joe maybe
nobody told you but you're supposed to
be the president in other words joe's
too busy getting his rest in delaware
every weekend he doesn't have time for
international travel by the way good for
boris johnson unfortunately joe doesn't
have the urgency
any urgency whatsoever when it comes to
any major issue and today he shouted he
squinted he lied a lot uh did it through
this speech about ghost guns and the
evils of american gun ownership during
yet another bizarre set of remarks you
know the hits they just keep on coming
take a look
when the cop knows
by first name who owns the corner
drugstore
who lives in the apartment above
6b who the people who are the the the
pastors of the churches
right now
you get let out of prison after serving
your time you get a bus ticket and 25
bucks
you end up under the same bridge you
left
two five ten years earlier
think about the mass
shootings as many as a hundred rounds
it's a weapon of war
i am proud to
nominate
steve
diddleback excuse me i mispronounced
your name i just
as director of bureau of
bureau of alcohol tobacco farms and
explosives
not great anyway make no mistake biden's
war on guns begins and ends with
law-abiding americans he is doing
nothing to stop the smuggling of weapons
and drugs across that wide open southern
border joe and he is doing nothing to
prevent crime guess what you can't
pursue happiness if you don't have law
and order and safety and security in
your town or your city or where you live
and if you don't lock up violent
offenders and you have no bail laws and
you defund the cops guess what that's
why crime is surging all over the
country instead he wants to limit lawful
americans and their ability to make
their own weapons a move that is clearly
obviously transparently unconstitutional
for a variety of reasons of course the
rule of law means nothing to joe also we
do have co-equal branches of government
and by the way that would be up to the
legislative branch to bring it to into
law and let the president sign it if he
wants to do it in a minute we'll bring
you the latest major development from
zero experience hunter and the biden
syndicate and by the way yeah the walls
are closing in very tight tonight hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else